robert badinter vite une situation
singulière
cet avocat bien envie c'est qu'il est
déjà entré dans l'histoire de notre pays
tout comme victor schoelcher à qui l'on
doit à l'abolition de l'esclavagé c'est
à badinter avant tout que l'on doit
celle de la peine de mort
comme toute évolution radicale elle fut
l'objet d'un combat dont rend compte
robert badinter dans l'abolition qui
vient de paraître chez fayard en 1972
robert badinter se rend compte que la
justice peut tuer
roger bontems complice de l'assassin
claude buffet mais qui lui n'a pas
commis de meurtre et guillotiné le
président pompidou ayant refusé sa grâce
quatre ans plus tard se déclenche la
sphère patrick henry cet homme qui
séquestrent et assassine le petit
philippe bertrand
ses défenseurs devant la cour d'assises
de l'aube robert bocquillon robert
badinter
on ne mesure plus ce que fut livré ce
sanguinaire qui s'empara de la france
entière télévision comprise on a oublié
les menaces physiques incessantes subie
par robert badinter et sa famille on a
remisé cette expression à trois c'est
pourtant c'est juste guillotiné c'est
qu'on perd un homme vivant en deux on
aura ceux de droite et de gauche qui en
conscience ont mis fin à cette
survivance barbare